that's all my ink i have this uh mic on
so yeah that's all right be a gentleman
and help me out with my question
hey
cody can you believe that marriage
didn't work out
i can't believe your relationships don't
work out
you want me to be a soft uh you know you
know one of those twitter tough guys
when guys come and sit on the couch i go
right after him do you respect me for
that no i don't your big dumb desk
hiding behind your microphone thank you
for keeping it real college yeah i kept
it 100 but when you kill somebody out
and then have them in front of you
that's punk no but then you can actually
just admit that you're wrong when the
guy's delivering because now he's
delivering he's still trying to oh yeah
he's not admitting that he's wrong
that's what i'm saying if we went to a
movie together would we sit next to each
other would you want to see between us
you know oh jesus because that's a tough
i want to sit like nine rows behind you
and just tug on your ponytail you savage
that's what i would do
i'm blind today i'm interested let me
help out before you yell at me
[Applause]
uh isn't your idol richard pryor
everybody
all right let's pray oh no you you don't
either richard bryant
good to see you like asking a guitar
player if he likes hendrix i mean he's
the man
all right he's the man see how you do
that you just ask me a question all of a
sudden i make it uncomfortable
i felt good right
make sure you're speaking to the mic
there you go you're whatever incognito
you're an enigma
what because i make a pie no you know
what it is you're not a good listener
you've known me for 10 years you have no
idea who i am it's all about comedy with
you and moving up the ladder and pushing
people a lot of people think that uh
they're uncomfortable with my uh my um
elevation are you uncomfortable with it
no i just see all of your insecurities
giant desk
you know i've been on the same tour for
this hour for almost over a year now
um dude bands tour for like four years
and then [ __ ] go right back in the
studio make another one and keep going
you got to toughen up man yeah you're
right huh yeah what do i do camouflage
hat looking like a [ __ ] backwoods guy
all tough and [ __ ] you can't handle
doing your hour again i mean come on man
suck it up
i heard you have a terrible theory and i
want you to say this so your theory on
boston is let's just wait till lebron's
old you don't want to be aggressive and
get players i didn't say that what did
you get misinformation what did you say
well why would you say i have a horrible
theory without checking with me first
it's like you already threw me under the
bus well i get it you got a big desk
this dude is knocking it out of the park
he's one of my favorites here is bill
burr
look at me look at you how are you oh i
know you did the audience
applause for everybody yeah there he is
come on
keep it going fall
while people are talking about eating
fake
that was before i don't want to be
responsible for that
i didn't but the kids
jesus [ __ ] christ i gotta tell you
the laker fans are even worse i can't
stand them at least yankee fans show up
at the start of the game those laker
friends they show up in like the second
quarter they had to get like botox
before they came down to the game oh no
ouch
but you like living in l.a i love yeah i
love la and i also love i like living
there i don't like their teams
i hate the jets i'm sick of people
saying i'm sick of people saying rex
ryan is confident he's not confident
that guy cries himself to sleep with a
vata ice cream every night
i'm not buying it
i thought you were laughing you were
[ __ ] yawning over here no the
mushrooms are [ __ ] killing me man
i knew it wasn't just weed i was just
like there's no way i'm taking a hit off
of that there's something going on here
mushrooms baby the shrooms i'm shrooming
[Laughter]
he's shrooming and he's wearing pants
like he went riding a horse today
like side saddle or some [ __ ] i'm just
gonna tell you how i discovered you
i you know i i do owe my whole career to
you yeah
i don't know i was struggling until
not discover you in terms of like
you did it on your own obviously but no
in terms of
my awareness of you
oh can i tell you that story i remember
it was a big day in my career
bobby lee is finally aware of me
am i on bobby lee's radar see this is
what he's got this is when things start
to happen i'm not going to allow this to
that reversal i'm not yeah i'm not going
to allow this to happen reversal yeah
yeah i'm just going to plug away you
know what i mean listen you can talk to
him all you want
i can hear it
really
is that is that you in action or is this
another photo shot
yeah it's a photo shoot people do photo
shoots yeah i know have you ever seen
like a movie poster and you'll see a
movie star he's clearly
five foot two yet somehow he's as tall
as the super have i have yeah that's
that's a photo shoot no fix stuff
look i'm sorry you're just on the web
man
you you took it this he took it to this
place i'm not trying to [ __ ] on his
website
what is it called again
huh zippitydoodah.com
we've never taken a break in the middle
of a gas station i know i had all this
momentum going on i got to start all
over again
go ahead go to the card
see this
we won game one
here comes the second of the double
header
because the older guys robert kelly's
and all they all call you billy colin
calls you billy but i [ __ ] bill i'm
just immediately noticing that i don't
know about the chain if it's if it's
thick enough to be that warrant that
level of confidence yeah
it's more
i love that you have the jib camera for
this like it's an action movie
let's let's let's swoop in at these two
guys sitting in these unbelievably small
chairs
i literally feel like i'm gonna fall
onto the floor this is insane
you really went all out with the
audience though they got full-sized
adult chairs
[Music]
headphones to work here some that'll
work let me see if these ones will work
hold on a second no they work good
my headphones aren't working for me
though oh okay
it's about me nick it's not about you
here here we go hey this is southside
steve and this is southside steve tv and
this is bill burr
that's your question
i'm just saying who you are oh yeah all
right i don't like you creeped me out
with that big microphone in that country
western shirt oh no this isn't country
western
it's like it's hip now to wear this this
is my nightclub look yeah come on
all right
this is this is i guess this is the
internet right you just sort of just
throw it out there i just throw it out
there i figure you're a funny guy
i'll throw it out there too well here's
the deal bill's a comedian he's at the
punch line he's in town and you're a
funny guy you've got these routines in
your head so i figure i'll toss you a
mic and you go and i'm gonna do stand up
in front of nine people in a radio
station no i'm not doing that well
you're taking the fun out of south side
steve tv i'll take uh how about i give
you five bucks i want to watch you line
dance and you're i'm a racist
your christian background is is part of
the the show yes and i wanted to talk to
you about jesus after that well
the only reason why i bring it up but
some people thought maybe you went a
little too far you know as far as what
well they thought that maybe you were
being disrespectful to the christian
religion
i'm telling you you need to google
oh good lord so did you feel you were
disrespectful or just you you were just
having fun with some of the crucifixes
and
stuff like that
i don't even know what yeah i mean we
did maybe two jokes about that yeah
exactly don't you think the catholic
church went a little too far
more so than my cartoon i listened to a
couple of jokes i know this is a morning
show you can't bring up all those crimes
you know what they just they just sort
of kept moving them around you know like
those killer whales at sea world after
it kills a trainer they'll then move it
up to seattle they don't give them their
background
all right i'm not totally following
but i don't know what i'm talking about
it's a morning show i understand
that kid would miss the graduation and
then it was a feel-good story
and we want to leave if you want to feel
good about america you watch the morning
shows you don't watch this you know and
one i was joking earlier if that kid's
story about the graduation was late
night that would have been a whole
different story what do you think he's
still missing we can't find him all we
found was his hat but you watch in the
morning it's great it all worked out he
got his own personal graduation like i
was in such a great mood look how yellow
this couch is it's like the sun but do
you like my mic no i don't i don't
please is that comfortable is this
uncomfortable this is yeah no don't man
honestly can i can i take the mic sure
now that's number the number one thing
you don't do
as i learned that in broadcasting school
you never give up the microphone see now
i have the power
this bob barker thing yeah you're uh
what is this rock 101.5
this is the worst interview i've ever
done and he's wearing stetson cologne or
something it's just really
over overpowering
you know what he looks like he looks
like the first guy who gets his ass
kicked in a steven seagal movie
the background guy behind the uh the big
kingpin wouldn't you handle this